der Bundesrat hat die neuen Corona
Regeln der beschlossene jetzt gerade und
das Gute das gibt es diesmal einmal auch
zu verkünden es gibt keine extra
knallheit Corona Regeln für Schüler ja
da ist er der Jubel an den deutschen
Schulen hier in letzter Sekunde haben
die Bundesländer nämlich Karl Lauterbach
diese knallhart Regeln noch ausgeredet
die Bundesregierung kippt also ihre
geplanten corona-regeln für Schulen ja
darum geht's Lauterbach wollte das
Schüler und Schülerinnen nach einer
corona-erkrankung erst mit einem
bestätigten negativen Test wieder zum
Unterricht zurückkehren das ist jetzt
gestrichen es war im übrigen vorher zum
Beispiel auf der Arbeit sowieso schon
nicht der Fall also da ganz ganz viele
haben sich beschwert haben gesagt schon
wieder machen wir strengere Regeln für
die Kinder als für die Erwachsenen das
ist aber jetzt durch meine gute
Nachricht es hat an der Tat einen
heftigen Protest gebraucht seitens der
Bundesländer bis man diesen umstrittenen
Paragraph 34 war es im
Infektionsschutzgesetz zurückgenommen
hat warum hätte man sowas machen sollen
bei Schulen das ist ja ein Rückfall in
die Zeit vor der